let's talk about this first big story
because this is this is really really
fascinating we've got from timcast.com
over 900 pages of coronavirus research
info at chinese lab released following a
foia lawsuit documents regarding the
work of the wuhan institute of virology
are now public
the 900 pages of documents were obtained
by the intercept through ongoing freedom
of information act litigation against
the national institutes of health the
collection includes specific information
regarding eco-health alliance a us-based
health organization and its use of
federal funding to uh to research bat
coronaviruses
the outlet also received two grant
proposals funded by the national
institute of allergy and infectious
diseases
gary ruskin executive director of the
u.s right to know said this is a road
map to the high risk research that could
have led to the current pandemic but
instead of taking it from tmps.com or i
mean and with all due respect this is
information coming from the intercept
who did the work on this one my respect
we have this statement
from richard h e bright verified on
twitter so you know he's legit
board of governors professor of
chemistry and chemical biology at
rutgers
he cites the articles and then
some quotes from the article and then
says
the materials show the 2014 and 2019 nih
grants to eco health with subcontracts
to the wuhan institute of virology
funded gain of function research as
defined in federal policies in effect in
2014 and 2017 and potential pandemic
pathogen enhancement as defined in
federal policies in effect in 2017 to
present
he says this has been evident previous
from evident previously from published
research papers that credited the 2014
grant and from the publicly available
summary of the 2019 grant but this now
can be stated
definitively from progress reports of
the 2014 grant and full proposals of the
2017 grant
and he ends by saying this because we're
going to read through everything but it
is
particularly damning
the documents make it clear that
assertions by the nih director francis
collins and the niaid director anthony
fauci that the nih did not support gain
of function research or potential
pandemic pathogen enhancement at the
wuhan institute of virology are
untruthful to put it very simply he is
saying fauci lied francis collins lied
and now i think most of us realized this
but uh
well now we're the documents what i
think is particularly fascinating is is
the intercept of all places that that
published this and so
for what it's worth we'll kick it off
with something i saw from glenn
greenwald
he said
if he was going to make a bet it was
that they were trying to actually
defend fauci and they may have
accidentally just proven he lied
i don't know what your thoughts on this
matter uh uh
zed
yeah i mean i can only speculate about
why they did it because um i wasn't in
touch with any of these reporters i
still know some people over there but i
wasn't in touch with any reporters who
did this story um i do think though that
if that's what they were trying to do it
you know it speaks well to them that
they would publish anyway i think we
need more of that in journalism is that
you have a certain worldview or you have
a certain hypothesis about the world you
go out there you look for evidence and
maybe what you find disproves that but
you publish it anyway i mean that's what
they do in science what scientists are
supposed to do is what the peer review
process and the journal process is all
about and so i think if that is what
glenn is saying is true it would
actually speak well of the intercept
that they decide to publish something
that goes against their worldview which
unfortunately i think is something that
you see less and less of in a lot of
these outlets these days you mean like
real journalism yeah i mean it's
literally journalism is about you know
journalism comes from the world journal
it comes from the word journaling
meaning that you're describing or you're
narrating the world as it is in front of
you
uh you don't really do that when you
start leaving out facts when you start
skewing things towards a particular
perspective there is a place for that
it's called advocacy right it's called
activism it's what politicians do it's
what people who are lobbyists do or
people in the nonprofit world often do
and that's fine and it's even i would
say i would even argue it's fine to have
journalists who have that particular
perspective and are going to go out from
that point of view but it becomes a real
problem when so much of the journalistic
world has converted itself into activism
because you're not getting people who
are just calling balls and strikes
you're not getting people who are
willing who have the resources and the
procedure and credibility to go out and
find the facts who will actually be able
to report them even if they go against
those preconceived notions or worldviews
it's kind of a damning uh
it's kind of a condemnation of activism
the idea that activists who are
supposedly fighting something good
are lying to you
i mean that's just that's just reality
right maybe propaganda's a better word
for it you know i'd like to imagine that
as an ad
as an activist if you come across
information that disproves what you're
trying to push you'd be like oh i was
wrong about that
i once did fundraising for an
environmental nonprofit they gave us
information on deepwater horizon they
sent us out to the streets to go ask
people for money because they're like we
want to raise awareness like literally
on the ground telling people as an oil
spill and then i was reading what they
had given us in terms of you know their
script and everything and then some guy
stopped and said you're lying that's not
what happened here's the news here's
what happened and i was like for real
like when i called my bosses and said
hey this is not true they said oh just
keep reading it anyway you're fine and i
was like what if we're not out here to
tell the truth
to tell people there's a problem and
we're misinforming them why would i do
this and so i was like nah sorry i'm out
yeah i mean i think that when you have
activists you have advocates yeah
generally speaking it would be frowned
upon just be outright making things up
or lying but i do think they tend to
just by the nature of their job they
tend to skew the truth or they tend to
arrange facts in a certain way i i mean
i wouldn't expect like the nra to start
saying okay well here's all the the
flaws with having liberal gun policy or
like letting everybody own a gun and i
wouldn't expect the brady control to be
saying here's 10 reasons why you might
want to own a gun for self-defense right
like we all anticipate that but what
happens when you start saying like cnn
or the associated press taking more
strident ideological or partisan
positions and they start being the ones
who won't be telling you both sides of
the story i think that is when it really
gets dangerous for democracy absolutely
yeah and and let's let's throw back to
these fact checks on on this reporting
when rand paul was clashing with with dr
fauci the craziest thing to me is that
rand is literally like here's a study it
says something like rich gene pool bat
chronovirus or whatever and he's like it
says in the study that you were making
chimeric viruses you were increasing
infectivity and this was funded by you
it says nih and then fauci's like no
that wasn't gain of function and the way
to describe is like imagine if a guy was
on trial for theft
and he says your honor i didn't steal
that piggy bank from that man's house i
simply walked into his house without
permission took the piggy bank and
walked out with it that's not theft like
you you literally just defined theft
right but what what do we end up seeing
a bunch of fact-checking outlets
misrepresenting what rand paul said many
left or liberal establishment outlets
started saying fauci owns rand paul and
they were highlighting a lot of things
like fauci saying you have no idea what
you're talking about instead of actually
the merit of this research study the
craziest thing was how reddit which is
like just bots basically read it as a
bunch of bots who just pump stories to
push propaganda and there were still
people breaking through being like i'm
cons confused why we're mad at rand paul
here he's right the study says you know
that this happened
so this is what's crazy to me
it's good the internet published this
it's like like you said it actually
reflects well upon them if they were
actually doing this to prove rand paul
wrong they decided to publish anyway
buzzfeed's done similar things where
they just they publish good stories
but what happened what do we say about
all these outlets that dismiss the story
as fake news as they've been doing with
basically everything like hunter biden's
son like what is that what does that say
about journalism today
yeah and i think this is like a big
theme of a lot of our recent posts that
uh at inquiremoor.com which is a
substance that we hold uh that we run um
which is that i think that a lot of
journalists now you know they're having
to choose between two missions one
mission is basically the traditional
journalism going out discovering things
about the world uh describing it as the
as the facts as they see them um the
other one is to promote a certain
worldview to promote a certain set of
values right and so i think that if
something like a virus has become
politicized which it has been in the
united states there's actually like a
red position and a blue position a
democratic possession a republican
position on everything kobe related now
unfortunately uh more so here in this
country than anywhere else in the world
i'd say also
which is an unfortunate aspect of it now
that you have journalists who kind of
adopted this sort of post-journalist
post-journalism mindset which is
basically an advocacy or an activist
mindset i think they see their goal and
their role as basically debunking or
disproving whatever this quote-unquote
republican position on coronavirus is we
saw this earlier in the pandemic when
they were all making fun of the idea
that a lab leak may have been
responsible for the pandemic now we
don't know where chronovirus or covet 19
came from we strictly speaking we don't
know we don't have the evidence for it
but they were so quick to dismiss this
theory and now you know even the bind
administration's keeping an open mind
about it even they have have uh not
reached a firm conclusion on whether or
not that's true with the might of you
know i have more than a dozen
intelligence agencies looking at it so i
think
that when you have journalists adopt
hard positions rather than keeping an
open mind rather than curious and uh
actually working to discover the world
and report out the facts you do get
things like a rand paul being mocked and
made fun of because they they made you
know they made up their minds before
that hearing ever happened that they
were going to take valkyrie aside they
were going to be against rambo they're
going to poke folk holes in rand paul's
argument they weren't going to do it in
faucet arguments um and that prevents
them from actually being able to do what
was done in this case with the hundreds
of pages of documents that were obtained
from through the foia by the intercept
was to actually go and look at the facts
and see what happened literally see what
happened and tell people what happened
and don't have an opinion about it don't
tell people how they should feel but
literally give them the information that
you any any reasonable person would need
to know how to how to think about this
problem or how to think about the actual
origins of this virus there is still a
challenge with this report and that's
who who was chosen by the outlet
as an expert
and so this this uh
we're sitting here being like wow you
know this this professor at rutgers has
said these things that are untruthful
and of course there's confirmation bias
there there have been several instances
where we have seen experts chosen
because their expert opinion might fit a
specific narrative now this one's
interesting because the intercept had no
reason to choose a professor who would
actually say you know about you lied so
in fact i have reason to believe this is
likely the case likely true
if you've like you you see this all the
time
where they'll be like you know a
feminist professor agrees with us that
feminism is good and i'm like yeah okay
well that's obvious isn't it or you know
this this critical race theorist
proponent is quote is considered an
expert on this release of documents and
they're going to say something positive
but when you see
a left or right wing outlet
actually saying hey the other side's
actually right on this one or this
here's evidence suggest i'm like that's
probably when it's true like it's so
glaringly true this story that even the
intercept had to be like
yeah voucher lied i mean they don't but
here's here's the best part the
intercept doesn't mention fauci
they don't mention he lied they just say
hey here's some information
and then
when you read it you're like wait a
minute sounds like fauci lied
is the guy gonna get arrested and
charged probably not
because i i guess we don't have
accountability in this country but i
will say
you know you you when you're talking
about journalism
i don't i don't know what happened but
maybe journalists didn't do enough to
inspire the the true tenets of
journalism in the younger generation or
the activists got into colleges and
turned j-school into activism
indoctrination camp or something look i
think part of this wasn't you know i was
working at think progress which was like
a left-leaning blog in 2009 which is
part of a left-leaning think tank and i
think a big part of it was that we had a
frustration always that we felt like the
news would be reporting two sides you
know side a says something side b says
something you know side b totally lied
but the news didn't really call them on
it the news just kind of weighed them
equally and you know they call that
false equivalence and so on and so forth
and there were times i think when news
outlets were doing that they were
getting stories very wrong just because
they weren't actually investigating what
was true because they were trying to
trying to provide balance to the story
but i think they over corrected for a
lot of that by basically saying that we
have we're basically now offering a
justification for being openly biased
right one side is clearly wrong there's
no point to go to them and get comment
from them there's no point to go and
even investigate whether what they said
is true they're clearly wrong just as
just as most of the press said that it
was clearly wrong that there was a lab
leak that resulted in kobit 19 which is
conclusion now that even the
intelligence community says is actually
possible they don't have the they don't
have a firm conviction on it so i think
that one there was an over correction
and two i think that it's just a reality
that
a lot of the younger generation tends to
be left-leaning and i think that those
are sorts of people that tend to go into
these industries or these fields if you
go to your average publication even if
it's something very mainstream like abc
news or cnn i will tell you like nine
out of 10 people who work there vote for
democrats you know or they're
left-leading or they're liberals and i
think that just having that level of
like
you know cloistered communities of
people makes it much easier to just
become very biased and not have anyone
call you on it not have anyone push back
and not have anyone at least provide a
dissenting opinion even if like i would
say 60 of journalists were left leading
or liberals it'd probably still be okay
because you'd still have enough like
conservative leaning people around or
people who have an open mind towards
that point of view to say hey you need
to consider x y or z or we need to go
and interview one additional person here
to provide that alternative point of
view but i think when it's so
overwhelming in a lot of these
institutions and institutions that feed
journalism you know for instance i wrote
a report
actually for the intercept a few years
ago about how
the majority of editors and reporters at
the new york times uh in the wall street
journal both came from a small sliver of
elite colleges like and we're talking
about i don't know how many colleges
whether it's probably under 30 or
something like they come from a very
tiny slice a tiny educational and
cultural segment of the united states
and i think when you're so closer when
you're so segregated from the rest of
the country it becomes much easier to
develop group think it becomes much
easier
to avoid any kind of dissenting opinion
or at least one person in the room is
going to stand up and say hey we need to
consider this other other side of this
we need to report the other side of it
because otherwise we're not telling the
whole story because i think a lot of
these journalists honestly do think
they're telling the entire story they
think what they're saying is completely
uncontroversial and you have to be kind
of nuts to disagree that's that's
honestly what they think i don't think
it's a conspiracy it's just like a
confluence of of these kind of
influences and these kind of cultures i
don't know i think a lot of them have uh
gone off like i think a lot of them are
evil right and i'll break that down
because evil is not a light word to
throw around i mean they they they
actively understand they're omitting
information like the daily beast for
instance like the daily beast is just
notorious
there's no way some of these articles
that come out you're going to tell me
this guy believes he's telling the truth
because some of these things that are
said are so
absurd on their face you're like how is
that even no but they'll write it
they'll publish it because their lawyers
tell them like yeah you'll be safe on
that one when you see when you see these
publications
putting out things that are just so over
the top you're like how could that
possibly be true but they don't care
they don't i don't think they think
they're telling the truth
well i think that there's probably two
things happening simultaneously one i
think there are a lot of these news
outlets have shifted to basically a
subscriber
kind of uh you know this is a subscriber
business model because the advertising
business model was being basically
dominated by a few digital firms like
google and facebook and so they wanted
subscribers new york times shifted
heavily towards subscribers after trump
was elected so one they have a financial
incentive to cater to a certain world
view and a certain type of person uh
that person is not going to complain
that much if they get stories wrong as
long as those stories have the right
sort of like you know oh you smeared a
republican who cares the republicans are
all evil anyway they probably deserve
they had to come right right so that's
happening at the same time they're
hiring up people who legitimately
believe a lot of these things right who
really deeply firmly believe that even
if their story isn't 100 fair
it overall is going in the right
direction so i'll give you an example um
you know ivermectin which is this drug
uh some people are using it for covid19
uh it's being called a horse dewarmer or
a horse drug in a lot of like major
press a major mainstream media i
criticized this um and there were
journalists who were very defensive and
saying okay maybe it's not exactly right
that's just a horse drug okay maybe it's
used for humans sometimes and it's
prescribed for parasitic diseases but
the other side is just taking you know
the other side just crazy they're all
conspiracy in that so like they see
themselves as part of an ideological
battle as long as they're on the right
side of that
if even if they're not being 100 fair
honest journalists they still see
themselves as morally justified i think
that's why they don't see themselves as
evil activism so so here's where i fall
with the whole ivormectin thing
there's conflicting studies data is
inconclusive fda has not authorized or
approved its use pertaining to coven but
the world health organization says that
it's an essential medicine that it's
used for treating river blindness that
it's basically eradicating this one
parasite and there are people who are
doing i i think people who are eating
horse-based are absolutely wrong to do
it and you know what we know they're
doing it because we had dr chris
martinson come on this show and say that
people were going to tractor supply and
doing and i'm like you shouldn't do that
there's a lot of reasons why you
shouldn't do that but to then go out and
say joe rogan announced he's taking a
horse dewormer it's like no he didn't
because there's tractor supplies horse
dewormer and then there's going to
walgreens to pick up your prescription
your doctor told you to get
now it's getting so over the top that
there's apparently reports that certain
pharmacies won't even fill prescriptions
like yo pharmacist you don't know what
the prescriptions for if a doctor
prescribes it just
say okay you're not the doctor
but that's the problem of
hyperpolarization that we're seeing
thanks for checking out this clip from
the timcast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time